[Music]
I'm a physician your dog is this
necessary medicine physician I married
care doctor
[Music]
72 hours since our first corona patient
will say - three and a half weeks it's
been about a month four weeks five weeks
ago this is a fifth week about five
weeks ago five weeks we saw our first
case at Northwestern and about six weeks
ago seven or eight weeks ago eight weeks
12 weeks we have two positive cases at
our facility currently the loss now we
have about 30 that's around those two
cases in total we have 94 patients in
the whole country in the ICU for the
whole of Washoe County I know there are
on 360
we have over 400 patient admitted in the
hospital we have a minimum of 400 COBE
cases in my facility today we've got
basically a 400 Beth hospital on a
day-to-day basis and it's virtually 100%
kovat at this point most of our folks
are changing in the garage completely
and sanitizing themselves before they
enter their homes I have wipes in my car
because I'm driving a patient to patient
so I wipe down my car before and after
every visit and then when I come home I
usually leave my jacket and shoes
outside of the house at least overnight
you change out of your clothes outside
of the home
you basically me immediately shower at
the hospital I have my protective
equipment stash in a place that I know
I'll be able to find it and gonna take
very close care of that protective
equipment as well you know disinfecting
my shoes immediately my clothes myself
their surroundings anything metal in my
home anything metal in my car is this
infected making sure that your phone is
in like it seal us containing or has
all of the kind of usual precautions and
then as soon as you're home making sure
any clothes that you've been wearing
even just out of hospital are kind of
thrown into the high degree wash I take
off everything before I go inside and
play my white bunny suits my gloves and
everything and I put outside for fresh
air to kill and then I or put in the
oven 70 degrees Celsius my masks and
then I took off my all my clothes
stripped completely down and put into
the laundry and then take a shower
takes about 30 to 45 minutes have
dedicated footwear to go back and forth
the hospital
I usually shower at the hospital but I I
leave my sneakers outside I could look
like soap on them I wash my cell phone
with alcohol my hands I take out all my
all of my clothes I put them on a
different basket in the laundry
psychologically it it is stressful
obviously I miss being around my family
a lot that's the hardest thing I am
having nightmares at night which I've
never had before in my life uh or
empezamos Connie insomnia a la noche que
uno no puedo Pagar de pensar en como
puede como puede hacer astrati Hijaz
para que dentro de esta pan de Maya
Camus an antiserum NT Vassar P hora por
esto que entra Mo's en el invierno
nosotros ahora pero si por lo menos
tengo a moose Tia Cole momento de go
away no venom ovm anymore viene do pero
es todo esto que estamos haciendo stea
bono que no la 10 Gamow to Sarto a la
cama Casey Tom preparado no moto de
Juarez
Wade ok Nate after this as the day
passes you learn how to put on your ear
you shower like three times a day it
becomes a routine with all of the new
changes and how protocols are switching
from day to day are those things enough
or you know are we gonna find out that
we need to be doing more or it is you
know sad to see a lot of these patients
you know be unventilated and things like
that you gotta be as professional as
possible as well broke down three weeks
ago in the middle of a shift I never
break down what's gonna happen to our
mental health afterwards what's gonna
happen to us afterwards you're gonna
have a huge wave of survivor's guilt
after this pandemic is over I mean it's
definitely been exhausting I want to be
really careful not to bring the virus
into someone's home I feel good because
I know that I I can do something for my
hospital and for my country or for the
people which is which is good makes you
feel good we're starting to see some
real hope for getting some of these
people back to their families and back
to productivity
a signal quiénes even a salami okay
danyoung que tienen Kisa para pacientes
of mitosis porque no you're kidding I
think if we aleatory oh I've had a
patient who's 84 who had seen once a
month for the last two years I have had
to tell him that I cannot see him at
home because I don't want to even take
the chance that if I were to come into
his home and potentially give him the
virus that would be extremely
detrimental to his health so I'm really
his only social outlet at this point he
doesn't have a close family and
otherwise and it's been really tough for
him to have to be in isolation without
proper care you know with someone he's
relied on the last couple years so the
decision as to when you intubate
somebody is particularly weighty one
with coronavirus because the data that
we have in our disposal shows that it's
difficult for many of these folks and
majority then suppose really to get off
of the ventilator so making that
decision has become it's already a
complicated decision so there were a lot
of difficult discussions over the
telephone with devastated family members
who had their relatives dying in
hospital nobody around and that was very
very difficult those conversations over
the telephone when you can't even really
build up the report that you'd like to
and because the telephone you can't see
people's emotions just crying and
unfortunately there are times when the
virus wins and we have to decide that
we've done all that we can for that
particular individual and nobody likes
to give up this patient we treated on
Tuesday she had been with a channelized
catheter for 15 years and she had no
access so we were trying to get some
venous access so she can get dialysis
because she could not be dialyzed for 10
days and she coated on the angio suite
and our decision was to what do we do we
don't have a lot of mental ators she's
more than 70 years old what's going to
happen but at the end we did
pulmonary resuscitation and the patient
is currently on ventilation she got one
dialysis but being unstable you
sometimes you cannot do the whole
dialysis but you always think that okay
this elder patient she's going to get a
ventilator then you could give to
younger patient and at the end while she
was not a common patient so we decided
to intubate her and give her all of the
maneuvers that we could I will say that
it is incredibly difficult from an
emotional standpoint to to interact with
patients and their family members we
don't let visitors into our hospitals
and there are no hospitals around this
country that do right our work flow
around that is different now and so it's
it's a it's crazy to tell someone hey
you know your family members quickly but
you can't come in here
right now one of the things that's
really been unusual for us is that we
are limiting the aerosolized medications
so the medications that we gave for
people with exacerbations of asthma or
wheezing or exacerbations of their COPD
they are really concerned about
aerosolizing and causing more spread of
infection so whereas normally when a
person had wheezing we would just put on
a mask and a nebulizer treatment not
even think about it now we really have
to make these decisions is the risk to
the patient and the crew of having this
aerosolized medication compared to the
benefit that they're gonna receive from
having those that we've English
shortness of breath relieved so yeah two
days ago I had a patient who was sick I
don't know yet if they were covered but
they were definitely in respiratory
distress I went ahead and gave the
albuterol treatment with the HEPA filter
on and then stopped it before we made it
to to the hospital and it did seem to
improve them so I feel like it was the
right thing to do but all the time I was
wondering you know is this one we stick
enough for us to go that way or should I
wait until they can have a different way
of delivering the medication fortunately
it worked out
you never had to think about it twice
before I think the hardest decisions
that we're having to make right now in
the US and around the world are in terms
of resource allocation and so continuing
to have to triage people and make
educated guesses about who most needs to
be tested and who's the most likely to
be infected continues to be a struggle I
think the hardest decisions still come
comes back to whether you need to order
tests for your your patient ideally that
would be good if we can do tests for
everyone but realistically they just no
resource to do that I think you know
treating patients with corona is the
patient that's asymptomatic I have you
know subsets of patients that one is
symptomatic and one is not who do we
test who do we not it'll be nice to have
a retrospective scope and say we could
have done anything better right the
issues that none of us human beings have
been relieved at at predicting things
all the time so otherwise we've been
prepared for this pandemic and it
anything we can do better is really to
asking humanity to change human nature
[Music]
this has taken a very big emotional toll
on me I miss my children I miss my
grandchildren and yes it has taken I
haven't cried yet but I've definitely
been on the brink a couple times
well most last time you cried right
before this interview I'm sure would say
I'm actually funded throughout patients
with you know really life-threatening
and serious problems and me being away
from home pales in comparison to all
those but it's certainly an an
experience that none of us will ever
forget as long as we're as long as we're
around like okay I'm doing this pretty
good thing for my country about what if
I get infected what if I infect my
family I cannot see my family and also
it's not it's not easy for anyone but
you have to stay positive if you start
thinking about like all the possible
scenarios you cannot live because you're
going to be scared the whole time and
stuff the whole time I can't remember
the last time I cried that night
it's definitely very emotional I mean
it's all been pretty hard to be honest
with you not being able to hold my
daughter or my newborn daughter the
tears haven't been shed yet because I
want to make sure that I'm a rock for
other people but this crisis team we've
actually all checked in we have our own
internal crisis team for the hospital
and every week we're rotating through
and making sure that we've got time
together that we're having those
debriefings when they're warranted and I
love the fact one of the nurses who sits
on this team actually stopped me in the
ER the other day as I was running like
racing by and grabbed my arm and said
how are you I'm good she says no really
how are you and really just kind of
nailed that home like I'm checking in
with you sister you know and when I was
in the hospital there were so many every
day you had an opportunity of realizing
that he crying would have been a good
way of you know releasing some tension
never cried for fear cried for patience
for situation for friends
well Domingo
el Domingo por que uno rocky shore @ o
el tiempo y que uno siente que si hassle
hospital y el mundo en a comparably map
Rio de voz de resolver lo porque es a to
funciona trata de ver como said jurgis a
2 cos a las ocho a la noche y como en
nogada care gada doula contract to de
perro eskimo bronchi no homo kundo he's
a lady - identify semen doses me take
mukha in Poona Bunnicula triste para a
new era a Samba letter he no hace que la
música de una bella coola yes a BM a
severe shudder in Eastern Europe
I think right now where we are in
Northern Nevada it's just at the
beginning we're going to be seeing a
flux of patience but I can see that it's
creeping up and that we are probably
just getting into the really high
volumes that other more urban areas have
been receiving already our rural
facility just does not have the capacity
to handle the bandwidth for large
volumes of patients we're exceptionally
social distance and systems put in place
have minimized a lot of patients being
exposed right now in Southern California
I think there's a glimmer of hope that
social distancing is working and I think
that we're gonna start to see more
regional differences in terms of
caseload and the attention span I worry
of folks has been somewhat used up
meaning that we've been under shelter in
place or stay at home orders for several
weeks now and we are beginning to see
some of the messaging on the news that
the numbers even in the worst-hit areas
are beginning to get somewhat better
this in my view is actually the most
critical portion of time where we have
to double if not triple down on all the
preventative measures that we're taking
as a society it also depends on whether
people get frustrated and they the
weather's really nice and they go
outside and take that risk
Lucey all you takes is one person to
encourage others to go outside to
encourage others in New York cities back
outside and we're spreading it to one
another you know it's a critical mass
then we're gonna be back into where we
were three weeks ago I think if people
don't don't stay at home this will get a
lot a lot worse it appears that in
certain areas things are starting to
improve and once we get testing more
readily available I think that will make
a big difference we are seeing that to
some degree with all and we are hopeful
that that we're at or perhaps just past
the apex of things guarded optimism
would be a good way to put it hoping
that we will see a trend down but that
string down will will take a long time
it's not going to be one week
two weeks and it's day by day my outlook
is cautiously optimistic about the
efforts we've done for curve flattening
I don't see the virus going away after
the surge I don't see it going away
entirely and I expect there to be
secondary peaks because of the
activities we've done so far at the end
of the day we're all gonna get through
this together the courage that I've
personally seen has been safe we will
look at feature that we will work for
saying cause they're not alone remember
you're doing important work well pass -
and we are going to make it through it
we can all learn from those experiences
you will never be prouder than you will
be looking back on what you did during
this time stay in touch with your loved
ones
thank you god bless you appreciate you
see know Know Who I am of nosotros in
1900 Chiara que vamos a salir de esta
vamos a Buddha resolver lo visto a gear
como mal sueño pero quiero ver para para
para que el futuro tose tengo mucho mas
preparados a poder a saloon esta
commercial anticipation never ever lose
the strength and the willingness of
communicate with people what is the real
need which is telling about isolation
telling about protection and in telling
that this is the solution a good
Hospital can save an important number of
lives a proper isolation is going to
sell millions of lives
you